after the presidential debate last week
which was mostly a shouting match and
and
it could have gone better let's put it
that way last night we saw
a really well manicured much more
old-style political debate you had two
politicians on stage
rather than a professional politician
and donald trump
where anything can happen you had two
politicians on stage
and in that battle mike pence just
mopped the floor with kamala harris the
best moment of the debate
was when pence landed the punch
that president trump tried to land on
biden that chris wallace was running
interference for
for biden so he wouldn't force him to
answer it was the question of whether or
not
the biden harris administration would
pack the courts
when you speak about the supreme court
though i think the american people
really deserve an answer senator harris
are you and joe biden going to pack the
court if judge amy coney barrett is
confirmed
i mean there have been 29 vacancies on
the supreme court during presidential
election years from george washington to
barack obama
presidents have nominated in all 29
cases
but your party is actually openly
advocating
adding seats to the supreme court which
has had nine seats for 150 years
if you don't get your way this is a
classic case of if you can't win by the
rules
you're going to change the rules now
you've refused to answer the question
joe biden has refused to answer the
question so i think the american people
would really like to know
if judge amy coney barrett is confirmed
with the supreme court of the united
states
are you and joe biden if somehow you win
this election going to
pack the supreme court to get your way
i'm so glad we went through a little
history lesson let's do that a little
more
in 1816 i'd like you to answer the
question mr vice president
speaking i'm speaking i i'm speaking
this was her only defense the whole
debate i mean
she went in unprepared she went in with
indefensible positions
and she went in against a seasoned pro
now there are pros and cons to being a
really good politician
the thing about donald trump is by the
old model he's not really a great
politician because
he actually does answer questions and he
actually does do things that are pretty
wacky and he's not all that manicured
there's a room for that too because i
think people get tired of the more stale
political format however when you got
politician versus politician
you got to go in recognizing how to play
this and she absolutely did not so the
only thing she had recourse to
was she would say i'm speaking and she
would kind of get more and more angry
about this all night i'm speaking and
you say
yeah well but answer the question you
know it's fine if you're speaking you
can read a litany of
of whatever you like but but i asked you
a specific question
she couldn't answer it why because she
knows if she says she won't pack the
court she's going to lose her base
she knows if she says she will pack the
court she's going to seem like a radical
there's nowhere for her to go and and
very likely they would pack the court
so he hits her on the court packing i
was the best one of the night the second
best one
was on energy biden and harris have been
very clear
they would ban fracking but now because
that's pretty radical because that would
really raise energy prices because that
would take away a lot of jobs
now they're trying to pretend that they
don't want to ban fracking and they tell
you with a straight face
they're not going to ban fracking they
tell you with a straight face they're
not going to try to get rid of fossil
fuels
mike pence knows how to twist the knife
we literally have spared no expense to
help the american people and the
american worker through this
joe biden and kamala harris want to
raise taxes
they want to bury our economy under a
two trillion dollar green new deal
which you were one of the original
co-sponsors of in the united states
senate
they want to abolish fossil fuels and
ban
fracking which would cost hundreds of
thousands of american jobs all across
the heartland
joe biden will not end fracking he has
been very clear about that
senator harris you're you're entitled to
your own opinion but you're not entitled
to your own facts
you yourself said on multiple occasions
when you were running for president
that you would ban fracking joe biden
looked at a supporter in the
eye and pointed and said i guarantee i
guarantee that we will abolish fossil
fuels i will repeat
and the american people know that joe
biden
will not ban fracking that is a fact
that is a fact that is a fact that is a
fact the problem
is that kamala harris said multiple
times during these debates
explicitly that she's going to ban
fracking
there's no question i'm in favor of
banning fracking so
yeah and starting and starting with what
we can
do on day one around public lands right
whoops
whoopsie daisy and you've you've heard
we've played on this show so many times
joe biden saying that he would it's ban
fracking no more fracking try to get rid
of fossil fuels so
she had no recourse she couldn't say
listen
on on august 5th i said definitively i
wouldn't be in fracking she can't do it
i mean also
as mike pence says she was one of the
senate co-sponsors
of the green new deal so what she chose
to do
was try to seem very smug very
condescending
kind of have this silly smirk on her
face all night
shake her head say no say when mike
pence uses
a cliche you're entitled to your own
opinion but not to your own facts she
was good lying there were other people
saying that on twitter
and mike pence delivered it well but
that is an old line that's they were
saying that as though they'd never heard
anybody utter it that's a classic old
politician line i think it was very
effective
but that's all she could get in that
snide comment yeah good line
yeah no and
mike pence on the other hand just seemed
so
sincere he just seemed so earnest all
the time
i've never seen anybody seem more
earnest so you had
you had this kind of performative
smugness
versus this performative earnestness and
i gotta tell you the latter played a lot
better at least from my vantage point
then they moved on
to foreign policy foreign policy another
area where
where pence was just ready to land
haymakers he comes in
and he brings up the big issue which is
china he brings up the big issue which
is the people who
destroyed the global economy because of
the virus the people who
have eaten america's lunch on trade and
manufacturing for 20 years
and crucially the people who president
president then vice president joe biden
cheered on
as we gave them every advantage in the
international
trading scene how would you describe
our fundamental relationship with china
are we competitors
adversaries enemies you'll have two
minutes uninterrupted
susan the trump administration's
perspective and approach to china has
resulted in the loss of american
lives american jobs
and america's standing
there is a weird obsession that
president trump has had
with getting rid of whatever
accomplishment
was achieved by president obama and vice
president biden
what come again what accomplishment
she's asked an explicit question about
china
here i'll tell you what let's let's role
play i'm kamala harris
if let's say i'm i'm running for vice
president you ask me is china our enemy
yes
no i didn't get to the other answers you
don't have to yes china's our enemy
china is our number one geopolitical
adversary
it's not even close but kamala harris
can't say that
because joe biden for decades said that
a rising china is good for everybody
in explicitly those terms and not so
long ago
he said it is a good thing it's good
that china is in the world trade
organization
it's good that china is being allowed to
grow their economy even at the expense
of the american economy even as they
steal property from us even as they take
jobs from us
and so she's got no answer to it so then
she has recourse to what
i think was a not very thinly veiled
racism accusation she goes you know i
don't know what it is about trump
he's got this weird obsession with
repealing
everything obama did so we mean it's a
weird obsession
obama is a radical left democrat trump
is a conservative republican
of course he wants to repeal all of his
radical
legislation and a radical executive
orders the only reason it would be weird
is the usual accusation that comes up
all the time
that that kamala harris made recourse to
last night which is race she played the
race card
whenever she didn't have an answer she
goes you know and i my mother came here
as an immigrant and i i'm very proud to
be the first black woman to be the vice
presidential nominee
nobody cares about that nobody cares
about that
we have had a black president it
we have had a female presidential
nominee
from a major party we don't you
it doesn't matter now right you say and
i could be
the if if joe biden is elected and then
you know he doesn't make it through his
term i could be the second black
president he's like well who cares
everyone cares about the first one
nobody cares about
the second one it's just so silly and it
was a way to evade
the questions and it was a way to evade
mike pence's
attack he finally and
by the way the first right out the gate
the first question was a loaded question
trying to go after
the trump administration on the
coronavirus this
this moderator who was much better than
chris wallace but again damning with
faint praise
this moderator was clearly on the side
of biden and harris
the difference was mike pence just
didn't care
right out the gates this was actually
the first question in the debate they
bring up
kovid and kamala accuses
trump and pence of killing all these
sorts of people all this terrible stuff
and then mike pence points out a
question that the mainstream media would
never
ask biden and harris which is what's
your plan
and he goes a little further he points
out that biden plan
that sure looks a whole lot like that
trump plan
we were able to reinvent testing more
than 115 million tests have been done to
date
we were able to see to the delivery of
billions of supplies so our doctors and
nurses had the resources support they
needed
and we began really before the month of
february was art to develop a vaccine
and to develop medicines and
therapeutics have been saving lives all
along the way
and under president trump's leadership
operation warp speed we believe we'll
have
literally tens of millions of doses of a
vaccine before the end of this year
the reality is when you look at the
biden plan it reads an awful lot
like what president trump and i and our
task force have been doing every step
of the way i mean quite frankly
when i look at their plan that talks
about advancing testing
creating new ppe developing a vaccine
it looks a little bit like plagiarism
which is something joe biden knows a
little bit about
oh man iron mike
just absolutely wrecking
biden right there at the end joe biden
of course
very famously infamously had to drop out
of the 1988
presidential race because he was
plagiarizing his speeches
so he gets that n comma here she doesn't
even know what to say
then mike takes it further the vice
president
says okay all right we've got all this
we all agree that our plan is great
thank thanks biden and harris i'm glad
you agree so now we're about to get this
vaccine so uh senator harris
you gonna take it you're gonna you're so
you're so interested in public health
you're gonna take that vaccine right
right if the trump administration
approves a vaccine
before or after the election should
americans
take it and would you take it if the
public health professionals if dr fauci
if
the doctors tell us that we should take
it i'll be the first in line to take it
absolutely but if donald trump tells us
i should that we should take it i'm not
taking it
oh it's so awkward so pence is kind of
teeing this up
and then you get the question from the
moderator which is okay well so
are you gonna take it and she can't say
yes now we are told oh my gosh we are
told
that we republicans are undermining
public health and
because we won't wear these masks you
know these dirty masks that
many epidemiologists have said we read
one just the other day from colombia
have said people are not using correctly
right the guy from colombia who's
speaking to npr
said that the masks fail in studies
because people just aren't
wearing them right so that i guess she's
going to do that obviously they're not
wearing masks during the debate
but then when the vaccine comes out
listen to the experts public health
she won't commit to taking it and mike
pence sees his opening and takes it
the reality is that we're going to have
a vaccine
senator in record time in unheard of
time in less than a year
we have five companies in phase three
clinical trials
and we're right now producing tens of
millions of doses
so the fact that you continue to
undermine public confidence in a vaccine
if the vaccine emerges during the trump
administration i think is
is unconscionable and senator i i just
ask you
stop playing politics with people's
lives the reality is
that we will have a vaccine we believe
before the end of this year
and it will have the capacity to save
countless american lives and and
your continuous undermining of
confidence in a vaccine is just
it it's just unacceptable mike pence the
silent
killer you just don't know when he's
going to sneak up on you
the rest of the debate went like that
you you get the picture i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts